foreign
will have heard that code vaccines saved
One Million Lives no wait it's actually
three million correction and and reduced
hospitalizations by like 18 million I
think this is the US only or is this is
the US only US Open
um and uh for instance new study I just
took off the person tweeting at because
I don't she doesn't need to be dragged
for this in particular although she
should really wake up since she claims
to be a medical doctor new study out
shows that covid-19 vaccines have
averted over 3 million deaths 18 million
hospitalizations and saved one trillion
dollars in medical costs in U.S and it's
a link to an article at
commonwealthfund.org hold on
um two years and
commonwealthfund.org two years of U.S
covid-19 vaccines have prevented
millions of hospitalizations
so I actually have Zachary a PDF of that
to show where I've got some stuff
highlighted let me just make it uh full
screen here okay you can show it now so
this is a PDF we will also
link to the link to the article on the
web this is the research in question
this is the research that finds that
three million deaths in the US have been
averted with these vaccines and 18
million hospitalizations and saved a
trillion dollars okay and it's out of
it's you know University of Maryland and
Yale and Yale School of Public Health
and all sorts of important places
well yes this research how how pray tell
did they uh did they manage to wrestle
this pattern from the data yeah well as
it turns out this is literally a blog
post so let's just start there like I'm
burying the lead here but this is
literally a blog post now this thing has
now been cited by well apparently
Anthony fauci himself this research is
now the biggest news in how amazing the
code vaccines are this is literally a
blog post this is from the same category
of people the same class of people who
throughout code when many of us have
been talking about papers on pre-print
servers that haven't yet been peer
reviewed oh you can't talk about that
because until it's been peer-reviewed
it's not real science this is a blog
post there aren't even any references
it's not even that they didn't include
the references but they clearly have
them there aren't even any references
Okay so
this ain't research they may have done
research and we're going to get to what
in fact they claim to have done but this
is all that is available that all of the
headlines and all of the doctors online
are referring to is a report in which
all of the actual stuff that was done is
completely opaque that's not how science
works okay so two connections one we've
seen this trick before Oh so many times
so many times the together trial right
we had a slide from a presentation for
more than half a year before they even
showed us the methods section which then
took experts weeks to unpack but it's
the Yale School of Public Health could
go wrong I mean these These are the
experts these are the authorities I'm
sure they've got glassware I'm sure
they've got lab coats I know they've got
the relevance I'm not sure they have any
of those things I know what they've got
though
grant money
um so can we show uh the clip of Anthony
fauci referring to this piece of
research before we get to what yeah I
think it's kind of the right order to do
it excellent yes let's do it so Zach has
that yeah
okay but the latest now Dr fauci is
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis he's now
asking the Florida Supreme Court to
Green Light an investigation into in the
way he put it is any uh any and all
wrong doing in Florida with respect to
covid-19 vaccines
what's your reaction to that
I don't have a clue Kate what he's
asking for I mean we have a vaccine that
unequivocally is highly effective and
safe and has saved literally millions of
lives the Commonwealth fund has come out
with a report just this past week that
vaccinations that have been administered
over this period of time this last year
and a half to two years has saved 3.2
million lives 18 million
hospitalizations and approximately one
trillion dollars in costs so what's the
problem with vaccines I mean vaccines
are life-saving so quite frankly Kate
I'm not sure what what they're trying to
do down there it kind of gets at a
bigger issue I've been wanting to ask
you as
um in one of our final interviews
um in in your role in public health is
just the reason one result of the
pandemic has sadly been that science has
become a divisive topic politicized and
weaponized by some people
have you thought about how do you pull
that back how do you turn that around
you know Kate if I had an easy answer I
I'd give it to you but it's a very
difficult situation you're absolutely
correct it has been politicized and it
has been politicized in a way that has
actually caused lives because if people
don't get
all right so that was unfortunately I
haven't seen that and I the way we have
things set up I couldn't hear it so I
don't know what he said so and that was
Anthony fauci
um in response to the question about
what governor DeSantis is doing with his
call for a grand jury uh that is Anthony
fauci saying I don't know what Ron
DeSantis is up to the vaccines have
saved you know a report out this week
says the vaccines have saved uh more
than 3 million lives
see what they actually did
I do
they uh
they took the assumption that vaccines
save lives
and they plug that into their model and
they said now let's imagine a universe
with vaccines that save lives and
without vaccines that save lives
and see if at the end of that running of
that simulation the universe in which
the vaccines which do save lives have
saved lives like at the end of the
simulation are more lives saved in a
universe in which vaccines that save
lives exist or
are there more lives saved in a world
without vaccines that do save lives
we they started with the conclusion
which we've also seen over and over and
over again and then they while law acted
surprised when out popped their results
so
in a model which is not data right they
plugged in an assumption which would
automatically give them an astronomical
number for the number of lives saved so
specifically just in terms of what they
did Zach if you would show my screen
again
this again the so-called research that
everyone is alluding to the the thing
that is not a research paper in any way
at the very end there's a how we
conducted this study section which in a
normal paper would be right after the
introduction between the introduction
the results and would actually spell out
precisely what was done and would
reference all of the claims that are in
any way not general knowledge already
how we conducted the study at the end of
this blog post
is
them saying basically what I just said
and then
vaccine efficacies against infection and
symptomatic and severe disease for
different vaccine types for each variant
and by time since vaccination we're
drawn from published estimates
that's it right that is the evidence
that is and and we don't even know what
the published estimates are
well this is this is Beyond scientific
malpractice yes this is this is complete
Insanity and is being you know all the
CNN viewers are now convinced that saint
fauci has spoken the word of God because
the Yelp School of Public Health has
just done this research which no like
they did something for sure but they put
out a blog post in which they buried the
actual thing that they did by saying
that their evidence that these vaccines
are effective was drawn from published
estimates what estimates were those how
were those gathered and were they
themselves accurate that is what we need
to know to know if the vaccine saved
lives they didn't they did not assess
anything to do with whether or not the
vaccine is actually saved lives here
right now I think there have been a
number of good analyzes of this and they
have discovered where the bodies are
buried here or not buried as the case
may be meaning they have they have
actually found their references they
have found the model on which these
things are built because this is of
course the second report from this group
and so there's a history right the model
in which it's built is one thing but
like the the the the
estimates I would Point people to Brett
Swanson's uh substack he's a data
analyst who has been excellent on uh on
questions regarding covet and he reveals
that this model in this case requires an
estimate of the number of people who
would have died from covid that
consistently exceeds the maximum number
that ever did on a daily basis right so
they have simply taken an absurd number
in light of a uh okay but that but
that's a different question I mean
that's that's a different problem with
the model right the problem that I'm
pointing out is they they have made the
claim that the vaccines save lives right
like far aside from the actual research
that we can see that they did here which
is
um which is given that we started with
the assumptions that we can't we won't
tell you exactly how how we made them
and exactly the nature of what they were
but now let's start with these these
these models of of sort of the
population and such that that's the
level you're talking about because that
is transparent-ish if you know how to
read this blog post right now what
you're saying is and I totally agree
with this this is a this is fraud
because it's being done by people who
understand why you can't do this this
isn't high school students right these
are presumably people who have studied
the data sets and know what you can and
cannot do I wouldn't have passed this
paper if it came to me in in as a
college because it doesn't matter what
level of study you're at this is
perfectly circular what they did is they
told older model that these were highly
effective vaccines at saving lives and
then they asked them whether they were
highly effective at saving lives it's
perfectly circular yes now
if you
for those of us who saw that clip of
fauci on CNN saying basically parroting
this as if it was a result which it is
not right it is a model right
for somebody like fauci to invoke that
number taken from this Source tells you
something that many people have been
reluctant to accept
this is a knowing lie all right Dr fauci
has plenty of training and a tremendous
amount of experience he knows the
difference between this and a result
that shows that this has happened so I
actually like with the amount of
skepticism that I've had to keep
actively on board for the last three
years now
I really thought I'm missing something
like this blog post is linking like i i
s and I still hope I'm wrong like where
is the research guys it's
well but it's it's not here but okay
take the alternative hypothesis which is
that from whatever point it happened
there was some idea of what we were
going to do and from that point every
decision has been subordinated to
whether it supports that plan or argues
against it and so any piece of evidence
that would get in the way of your
vaccinate everyone program has been uh
obscured and every uh result no matter
how garbagey no matter how circular no
matter how much it is based on models
that are not actually evidence of
anything it is it is promoted to the
very highest levels right to have
Anthony fauci on CNN say a knowing lie
and it can't be anything else
incompetence does not explain why
somebody with a full career's worth of
experience in this exact field would
parent a result this dumb he's a lot of
things but dumb bunny he ain't he ain't
a dumb bunny
um so and then but the this result
you've probably seen it you and I have
not been together since this result came
out we've been in separate places but
I've seen it in many many different
places everybody on the blue team is
championing this as like see we were
right new data right no actually no new
data at all this is actually a good
moment to reveal that Tony is in fact
our Lord and savior if you could show my
screen here this editor-in-chief of
Science magazine this week published
this editorial in science the headline
is thank you Tony
okay so he the editor-in-chief of
Science magazine one of the two premier
science journals in the world uh has
done an interview with Tony fauci and
he's just put some of the highlights
into this thing and then you can go
listen I have not uh you can go listen
to the whole interview if you like
um Anthony fauci Tony to friends
colleagues so many journalists has never
backed down from controversy it begins
just a few quotes here
we talked a lot about this the
editor-in-chief of Science and Tony
fauci we talked a lot about
misinformation and the forces sowing
doubts about covid-19 vaccinations
interventions such as masks and
lockdowns
did you
'd love to hear that we agreed that one
of the biggest challenges with which the
scientific Community must grapple is
misinformation that comes from within
I ran to that like a stone wall at a
congressional hearing he said describing
how his skepticism of an argument put
forward by researchers who questioned
the necessity of covid-19 lockdowns was
met with admonishment quote you're
arrogant because you're disrespecting
other scientists he was told fauci's
response quote you don't want to be
disparaging of anyone but you've got to
come back and push against those things
that are not true
I like this is so backwards and upside
down and one more thing we also talked
about how we need to do a better job of
conveying that science is a process and
not a collection a collection of facts
set in stone nowhere is it a guy named
Anthony fauci frankly
well okay but so can you can you believe
this guy I don't like the way they've
titled this I think it really should
have been titled oh Tony your science is
so big
science Me Harder Tony or something
right
no but it's the Christmas season so I
think all right so they toned it down
for their kids but no he's he's Christ I
mean they're making them and they're
they are they are and you know well
that's that's a that's a promotion
because he was just science before and
now now he's both now he's
ascended yes he is ascended in his uh
stepping down from from his former role
um but okay
this is frankly right if there wasn't so
much writing on all this this is funny
right the fact that people cannot help
but die from the terrible advice and
treatments they're getting makes this
utterly ghastly but the absurdity of it
would be funny otherwise but I wanted to
point out this isn't just
the science types and the science
journals getting tangled in knots about
this and your doctor giving you bad
advice the public it's not just all of
that it's not just all of that what's
happened is they have carved out the
space to make a completely fictional
scientific reality that is not obligated
to match anything in the actual real
world anymore and everybody who you know
signed up for the idea that they were
the real scientists is now being carried
into this fantasy Science World along
with them can you show the um the
Stephen Colbert clip
lives
so to take full command of the GOP all
DeSantis has to do is reel in the
coveted conservative demographic of
angry conspiracy Q Anon all meat diet
tand your testicle boys
[Applause]
and his opening offer to all of them is
calling for a grand jury investigation
of covid vaccines
you stupid motherfizer
questions
you want an investigation let me save
you some time and money in the U.S alone
the coveted vaccines have saved more
than 3 million lives and help prevent
and helps prevent
18.5 million hospitalizations and
if that's not enough and because idiots
in your party politicize the vaccine
almost twice as many Republicans died
from covid before the midterms than the
Democrats y'all killed your own boaters
it's the stupidest political strategy
since the Whig slogan of 1840 Tippecanoe
and taunt a grizzly
all right now that I think was it the
drummer in the background that they
showed I feel like there was one person
in the band I think the drummer the
woman in the background who did not look
thrilled
I have hopes I I you have hoped yeah
well what shocks me about that I mean
not only has this blog post taken on a
life of its own as if it were just true
it did come out of the Yale School
Republican I guess it did but
um not only is it being uh
rendered into this phony reality as if
it was actually like three million
people alive who otherwise wouldn't be
right a complete bit of nonsense but the
uproarious laughter and Applause at this
the idea that this is so transparently
correct that this audience of
sophisticated people is you know ready
to just laugh at the beauty of what
we've done with these things it's
tribalism and it's dehumanizing it's you
know this this continues this you know
blue team loves to argue that it was
Trump who turned the American political
system into the complete Carnival that
it is today that it was yeah it was
going there and like you know Newt
Gingrich started in the 90s and all of
this and it goes all the way back but it
was really Trump who did it and
they need it now and I God is that the
first time I've referred to them as them
maybe but you know blue team needs the
division needs the dehumanization needs
the tribalism in order to keep
I don't even know what they're trying to
keep they're turning it they're trying
to keep the power and the fact is they
actually can't afford not to have the
power yeah because
um what they've done is
so dangerous and so harmful and frankly
if one is allowed to do a proper
investigation it's not that hard to
prove right these are not it's not a
complicated question at a scientific
level you know did these so-called
vaccines uh increase the level of
all-cause mortality or didn't they right
that's a relatively straightforward
thing to test as as Christine stable Ben
has shown
foreign
[Music]